[Music]
still today cause there ain't no doubt I
love this land
there we are Donald Trump has arrived in
the room let us see him walk
I'll be greeting a couple of his
supporters there
perhaps treating it to like a campaign
rally although you have to say that
image of him in the courtroom earlier
was affected by the charges he is facing
the indictment 34 felony counts which he
has denied
there is meeting his supporters
500 of them of course some of his family
and in a circle too
many Republican and Congress people
there archery Taylor green that one
Senator scene
so let's just uh watch the 45th
president of the United States the only
one the very first one to face criminal
charges
it is let's not forget now a criminal
defendant a criminal defendant who is
determined to secure the Republican
nomination to stand for the White House
once again
so there he is he is in the room it's
been a long day hasn't it for the 45th
president of the United States
and uh there he is
um Michael McAuliffe um just we probably
won't hear Donald Trump speaking for a
moment although maybe wrong because
meeting some of his supporters isn't he
I don't know if you can see the pictures
there he is so can you what do you make
of his demino as he walks into the room
there Donald Trump he has had a long day
but he has he looks resolved
and he looks like he's starting a
campaign uh rally and here we here he is
he's just walked up for two perhaps the
podium there and they think he's about
to speak here is Donald J Trump
[Applause]
thank you very much everybody we have to
save our country
God bless you all God bless you all
and I never thought anything like this
could happen in America never thought it
could happen
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it
from the beginning the Democrats
spied in my campaign remember that
they attacked me with an onslaught of
fraudulent investigations Russia Russia
Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine
impeachment hoax number one impeachment
hoax number two the illegal and
unconstitutional raid on Mar-A-Lago
right here
lying to the fisa courts
the FBI and doj relentlessly pursuing
Republicans
the unconstitutional changes to election
laws by not getting approvals from state
legislators
the millions of votes illegally stuffed
into ballot boxes and all caught on
government cameras
and just recently the FBI and doj in
collusion with Twitter and Facebook
in order not to say anything bad about
the hunter Biden laptop from hell
which exposes the Biden family as
criminals in which
according to the pollsters would have
made a 17 point difference
in the election result
and we needed a lot less than that like
about 16.9
it would have been in our favor
not my favor our favor because our
country is going to hell
and we remember the 51 intelligence
agents
who said Hunter Biden's laptop was
Russian disinformation
it didn't exist it was Russian
disinformation remember that
and that was all confirmed strongly by
the FBI
when they all knew that it wasn't
Russian
disinformation
and so much more our elections were like
those of a third world country
and now this massive election
interference at a scale never seen
before in our country
beginning with the radical left George
Soros back prosecutor Alvin Bragg of New
York
[Applause]
that
he would get president Trump I gotta get
him I'm gonna get him this is a guy
campaigning
you want to get president Trump at any
cost and this before he knew anything
about me didn't know a thing about me he
was campaigning
as it turns out virtually everybody that
has looked at this case including rhinos
and even hardcore Democrats
say there is no crime
and that it should never have been
brought
never have been born everybody
even people that
aren't big fans have said it they said
this is not the right thing to do
it's an insult to our country as the
world is already laughing at us for so
many other reasons like our open borders
are incompetent withdrawal from
Afghanistan Where We Left Behind
American citizens 85 billion dollars
worth of
the best military equipment in the world
lost 13 magnificent young lives and far
too many
to mention that are so badly hurt with
the loss of arms and legs and facial
obliteration
the most embarrassing time in our
country's history in my opinion
then our give up on energy Independence
and even energy dominant we're going to
be dominant within six months more than
any other Nation times two
we had this all just three years ago our
raging
crime statistics if you look in
democrat-run cities numbers the likes of
which we have never seen before
the open threats by various countries
of the use of nuclear weapons
something never mentioned or discussed
by outside Nations during the Trump
Administration in which
could very well lead under the Biden
administration's leadership to an
all-out nuclear world war three can
happen
we're not very far away from it believe
it or not
an economy that has been crippled by the
biggest inflation we have seen in more
than 60 years
and a military that I use to defeat Isis
in four weeks they said it would take
four years
four weeks to kill al-baghdadi and
solomani
that has now gone woke at the top Levels
by trying to indoctrinate everyone down
to the lowest ranking Patriot
but now they have really stepped up
their efforts by
indicting
the 45th president
of the United States who received
[Applause]
75 million votes which is more than any
sitting president in the history of our
country
and in the wings they've got a local
racist Democrat district attorney in
Atlanta who is doing everything in her
power to indict me
over an absolutely perfect phone call
even more perfect than the one I made
with the president of Ukraine remember a
kid kept saying that's a perfect call
this one was more perfect
nobody said sir you shouldn't say that
many people on the phone
or hung up in disgust because of
something I inappropriately said
because nothing was said wrong in fact
at the end of the call we agreed to
continue our conversation about election
fraud
and election fraud specifically in
Georgia
at a later time many people on the phone
including lots of lawyers nobody found
anything wrong with that perfect call
until a book promotion to her
many months later all of a sudden they
say you know I remember Trump making a
call
let's look at that this fake case was
brought only to interfere with the
upcoming 2024 election
and it should be dropped immediately
immediately
[Applause]
then you have a radical left lunatic
known as a bomb thrower
who is harassing hundreds of my people
day after day
over the boxes hoax you know the boxes
hooks as we call it
just so everyone knows I come under
what's known as the presidential records
act which was designed and approved by
Congress long ago just for this reason
under the ACT I'm supposed to negotiate
with Nara the National Archives and
Records Administration
which as of this date is a radical left
trouble making organization that red
flags the Constitution of the United
States and the Bill of Rights says
dangerous and triggering can you imagine
this is what we have to deal with
but there is no criminality under the
presidential records Act
that is not what it's all about
we were negotiating in very
good faith proper way in order to return
some or all of the documents that I
openly and in very plain sight
brought with me to Mar-A-Lago from our
beautiful white house just as virtually
every other president has done in the
past
when FBI and doj officials with narrow
with
here
I told my lawyer to show them the
very secure storage room
in which they were locked
the FBI sold request in writing was
could you please put another lock on the
door
we immediately complied
it's a lot different than the Biden
situation isn't it
the next thing I know we were rated by
many gun toting FBI agents
who took whatever they wanted including
my passports and medical records
everybody was in shock nobody had ever
heard of such a raid before we can't
even believe it who would think that
that could happen today
I immediately thought of the fourth
amendment that protects against
unreasonable search and seizure
but they did it anyway because our
justice system
has become Lawless
they're using it now in addition to
everything else to win elections
apparently they're not looking at me
through the view of the non-criminal
presidential records act they came up
with a new one this is a new one
and they're looking at me through the
Espionage Act think of that how does
that sound of 1917 where the penalty
is death
even though that is absolutely nothing
to do with openly taking boxes of
documents and mostly clothing and other
things to my home
which President Obama has done the
bushes have done Jimmy Carter's done
Ronald Reagan has done
everybody's done in fact
Hillary Clinton got rid of 33 000 emails
and that was okay
but nobody's done it like Joe Biden
this lunatic special prosecutor named
Jack Smith I wonder what it was prior to
a change
who others of his ilk say
he is even worse than they are
is only looking at Trump yet Joe Biden
took massive amounts more documents even
removed many boxes to Chinatown
you believe that she's got 10 million
dollars from China where did that come
from I guess they were banking on
Hunter's expertise
and had others stored in unsecured
offices in Pennsylvania and strewn all
over his garage floor where his now very
famous Corvette
is also stored
all over the floor including classified
documents
but that's okay
perhaps most importantly he has
1850 boxes in Delaware
which he is refusing to give up
but isn't that real obstruction that's
obstruction as president I have the
right to declassify documents and the
process is automatic
if I take them with me it's automatic
Declassified
Biden was vice president
he had absolutely no right to declassify
as vice president
he doesn't come under the non-criminal
presidential records act he comes under
the very criminal Federal records act
unfortunately for him but it's not going
to matter because they don't follow the
law
which has very severe penalties
he had classified documents that he took
while he was a senator
which is absolutely inexcusable and
other Senators including Democrats
are outraged
but he's not being harassed and hounded
like the people
who work for me are
in fact they seem to have forgotten
about his documents entirely so many
thousands and thousands okay with him
they like to say that I'm obstructing
which I'm not
because I was working with Nara very
nicely until the raid on my home
but Biden is obstructing by making it
impossible to get the 1800 and 50 boxes
or explain why many documents were
located in Chinatown can't explain it
why were they each other I don't know
lastly I'm under investigation
this time a civil investigation by
another racist in reverse
who also campaigned on I will get Trump
I will get them
this was our campaign never ran for
office I will get him
her name is Leticia James
[Applause]
and she proclaimed while campaigning
quote I look forward to going into the
Office of the Attorney General every
single day
suing him and then going home
before she knew me
she announced what is fueling my soul
right now is Trump
and that she had her eyes on Trump Tower
those eyes are focused on Trump Tower
didn't know the young lady
she even assured her supporters in an
election promise that we're going to
definitely sue him we're going to be a
real pain in the ass
he's going to know my name personally
and then she claimed that I was an
illegitimate president I think you ever
think of that with all
with all we did with all we did on
energy with all we did on the military
on taxes biggest tax cuts in history
biggest regulation Cuts in history
right to try
people able to get drugs now that aren't
approved
hopefully you don't have that problem
Leticia James vowed to use every area of
the law to quote investigate president
Trump and his business transactions
those transactions are going to be
investigated she said
and that of her family
and his family
because we're going after his family and
we're going after them hard
this is all before entering office and
all before knowing anything at all about
me but you're gonna get me
this is why along with unrelenting crime
so many people and companies are leaving
New York
she said that I falsified my financial
statements but in fact we're proving and
we'll prove that my financial statements
were substantially more than we
submitted not less
and in all cases have a strong
disclaimer clause in them which tells
the institutions that may look at that
if they want to
not to lie on the statement
but they've got a problem with their
case because number one I'm
very under leverage they can't believe
it all the stuff they read and gave
and have very little debt relative to
the value of assets
and importantly not One bank has lost
even one dollar she was investigating me
to save Banks they have very good
lawyers
but they didn't lose a dollar with us
during this period of time
in fact the banks
were talking about
made almost 200 million dollars off
Donald Trump
and they liked me very much
we never missed a payment never got a
default notice had a great relationship
with all of them
I don't need Banks we have a lot of cash
I built a great business with my family
built a fantastic business
[Applause]
I have a son here who's done a great job
and I have another son here who's done a
great job
[Applause]
and Ivanka and baron will be great
someday he's tall he's tall and he's
smart
but I have a great family and they've
done a fantastic job and we appreciate
it very much they've gone through hell
so she's suing me over banks that
weren't defrauded when she should be
focused on violent crime that's driving
people out of the state
this is a persecution not an
investigation she's put our family
through hell it's cost hundreds of
millions of dollars to defend
but our heads are held very very high
they want to settle the case but I want
no part of that
so here we are now
it's where we were today
in a city that was
so gracious four or five years ago
but now we're there
spend time there today as you possibly
read
with a local failed district attorney
charging a former president of the
United States for the first time in
history
on a basis that every single pundit and
legal Ana said there is no case there's
no case they kept saying there's no case
virtually everyone
but it's far worse than that because he
knew there was no case
that's why last week he delayed for a
month and then immediately took that
back
and through this ridiculous indictment
together came out today everybody said
this is not really an indictment there's
nothing here
my lawyers came to me and they said
there's nothing here they're not even
saying what you did
the criminal is the district attorney
because he illegally leaked massive
amounts of grand jury information
yeah
for which he should be prosecuted
or at a minimum he should resign
and Alvin Bragg's wife confirmed a
report that claimed her husband has
Trump nailed on felonies
she has since locked down her Twitter
account
his chief prosecutor who represented the
Democrats and crooked Hillary Clinton
and
a firm run by Chuck Schumer's brother
Robert
he quit the firm in order to go to work
in the D.A office in order to get Trump
can you imagine that Hillary Clinton's
lawyer Democrat lawyer Democrat firm
ultimately he
quit as Chief prosecutor because Bragg
didn't think he had a case think of that
same guy that brought this ridiculous
thing today
yeah during his investigation
this prosecutor named Mark pomerance
wrote and published a book
saying all sorts of privileged things
and has been very strong
he was reprimanded so strongly I've
never seen anything like it at probably
the end of it
but
what he did was probably very illegal
but he was very very strongly
reprimanded
even district attorney Bragg was furious
with him they were having a tremendous
fight in the office because of it
but hope is never lost because various
prosecutors in the Ada's office also
quit because they thought president
Trump was being treated very unfairly
how about that isn't that great oh I
love them I'd like to meet them
I'd like to meet them
[Applause]
the DA's office
even had a web page
meet the team of Executives who have
done this to president Trump that was
the title isn't that nice they
immediately had to take it down
meanwhile overall crime in New York was
up 30 percent last year
much more than that the year before with
felony assaults robberies and burglaries
all up by massive massive numbers
not the same place that I know not the
same place that you know
and this is where we are right now I
have a trump-hating judge
with a trump-hating wife and family
whose daughter worked for Kamala Harris
and now receives money from the Biden
Harris campaign and a lot of it
we recently had another trial and the
same judge told the fine man who worked
for me for many many years
that if you admit your guilt
you will be in jail for 90 days
but if you don't
if we go through a trial and you're
found guilty you're going away for 10
years and maybe longer
which for a 75 year old man with a great
family
really means life
what the prosecutors and judge did to
that man I will never forget
because it's right out of the old Soviet
Union that's where we are
they said you say anything about Trump
meaning that's bad
and you won't even have to serve the 90
days you'll walk free
and they say that to many of my
employees
we have this Jack Smith lunatic
threatening people every single day
through his Representatives
they're threatening jail terms
but talk about Trump and you'll go free
this is where we are as a nation who
would have thought
they can't beat us at The Ballot Box so
they try and beat us
through the law
that's the country in which we live
however right now the USA is a mess
our economy is crashing inflation is out
of control Russia has joined with China
can you believe that
Saudi Arabia has joined with Iran
China Russia Iran and North Korea have
formed together
is a menacing and destructive Coalition
would have never happened
if I were your president would never
have happened nor would Russia attack in
Ukraine have happened all of those lives
would be saved all of those beautiful
cities would be standing
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard
which will be our greatest defeat
frankly in 200 years there will be no
defeat like that
that will take us away from being even a
great power
if you took the five worst Presidents in
the history of the United States
and added them up
they would not have done near the
destruction to our country as Joe Biden
and the Biden Administration have done
incredibly we are now a failing Nation
we are a nation in Decline
and now these radical left lunatics want
to interfere with our elections by using
law enforcement
we can't let that happen
[Applause]
with all of this being said
and with a very dark cloud
over our Beloved Country
I have no doubt nevertheless
that we will make America great again
thank you very much God bless you and
God bless America thank you very much
everybody thank you
and there we are Donald J Trump
has spoken in that speech lasting around
25 minutes
um let's reflect uh briefly on uh what
he had to say that was the first time he
has spoken for uh since being formally
arrested addressing his supporters there
at Mar-A-Lago his state in Florida hours
after he became the first current or
former U.S president to be formally
charged with a crime so what did he say
he claims he is the victim of election
interference of course he's hoping to be
the Republican candidate again in
2024 he has called it a fake case which
he says should be dropped immediately it
also hit out a New York prosecutor
Manhattan prosecutor Alvin Bradford
bringing criminal charge is against him
said he was the criminal so he never
thought anything like this could happen
in America Mr Trump said the only crime
that he had committed was to fearlessly
defend our nation against those who seek
to destroy it and he said America's
justice system had become quote Lawless
he accused the judge didn't he being a
trump hating with a trump-hating family
and a lot of his ire was directed to the
current president of the United States
uh pretty much concluding if you add up
the five worst Presidents they haven't
done as much damage as Joe Biden has led